try to wanna grow up fine twice reckon
the guy after 70 years of business Toys
R Us announced yesterday it's closing
its doors in America looks like everyone
has to grow up sometime a Peter
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the never-never-land of the internet
that's Peter Pam's never-never-land not
the creepy Michael Jackson Neverland if
you haven't guessed it yet today we're
exploring the world of Disney's favorite
narcissistic tween heartthrob Peter Pan
as you're probably aware cuz I say this
literally every Disney episode growing
up I loved all the Disney movies except
for Pinocchio but who didn't want to be
Peter Pan he had the ladies fighting
over him constantly which is
inexplicable when you think about what a
creeper he actually is in his own movie
ooh here's a mystery boy who sneaks into
my bedroom at night and talks only about
himself
gee a piece of that so really the big
draw here is obvious everyone wants to
be able to stay a kid forever and play
video games and avoid the IRS cuz taxes
suck but you can't be Peter Pan and stay
young forever unless you figure out
where Neverland is and also grab some
fairy dust and fly there and defeat some
pirates the one thing at a time people
the geography is clearly the hardest
part until today that's right the
mission for today is to find the
geographic location of Neverland sounds
absurd right but we're actually given
plenty of hints throughout the movie in
books second star to the right and
straight on till morning and all that
jazz even jamberries original book
describes Peter and the darling children
flying over the ocean to get to
Neverland but he just never specifically
says where they choose to land in the
original versions there's no mention of
a star at all he just says second to the
right and then straight on till morning
but I'm not talking hints I am telling
you today that I have definitively
located Neverland to the point that you
can actually book your next vacation
there and start taking all the
swashbuckling and Native American themed
racism you want
so sprinkle yourselves with Theory dust
and think happy thoughts next stop is
Neverland to start we need to remember
that Wendy John and Michael darling live
in London when Peter tells him that
Neverland is the second star to the
right and straight on till morning
it seems a really vague but actually the
scene gives us plenty of clues to
determine which direction they're headed
first I compared this frame of the movie
to constellations that could reasonably
appear in the London night sky well we
don't get anything too conclusive we can
actually speculate that these stars here
might be Mizar and Alcor
which are in similar positions to what
we see in the movie though in real life
they should appear to be part
Big Dipper constellation anyway there's
no need to get out your astrolabes just
yet because the good news is we actually
don't need the exact stars that they're
looking at we can tell which direction
the kids are facing just from the
landmarks around them after flying out
of the nursery the kids in peter land on
one of the sides of the elizabeth tower
clock the east side to be specific now i
already hear you but actually people
cracking your knuckles preparing for a
wave of comments saying but actually
that's not elizabeth tower that's Big
Ben but a fun fact Big Ben is the
nickname of the Bell inside of the
Elizabeth tower so feel free to annoy
all your friends with your pedantic
knowledge of London landmarks anyway how
can we tell that they're facing east
well look at the shot of Peter of the
darlings flying up to the clock in the
bottom right we can see a statue of a
horse rearing up and that is in fact the
statue known as the Buddakan rebellion
statue which commemorates an ancient
celtic queen who drove the romans out of
london yes Queen that statue is located
to the north east of the town so they're
landing on the east side going to the
right would be them flying south but we
get an even more specific idea of the
direction by tracking their flight they
fly over Westminster Bridge facing east
and they make a sharp turn over the
bridge so sharp that the camera has to
rotate to follow Peter to head southwest
and that's the direction the camera
follows them until they get to Neverland
TLDR they're going south and west of
London which indicates that they're
making a transatlantic flight towards
the Americas so now that we know they're
headed to North or South America we can
look at a few other factors to help us
narrow down the search for Neverland
judging by the map that we see of
Neverland we're looking at an island
that's fairly small and features a
number of inlets and lagoons typically
there are two types of lagoons of the
Americas coastal lagoons which are
connected to the coastline of a much
larger landmass and at Ola beads which
are more isolated and formed by coral
reefs by the looks of it there are no
major land masses in the waters around
Neverland so we can conclude that
Neverland is an atoll now atolls require
coral reefs and tropical waters so that
narrows our search a lot from the
southern tip of Florida throughout the
Caribbean and down through the code
in Brazil but geography is just the
beginning we also know a lot about
what's on that island notably raka dials
assuming this crocodile didn't escape
from the zoo or from Suicide Squad
though who can blame him for wanting to
escape that movie we can pin fleet never
lands location if we know the species of
crocodile there are only two species of
crocodile indigenous to the waters
around Latin America more or less
crocodile and the American crocodile
well both can take your hand off pretty
darn well morelets crocodile is a lot
smaller than the American crocodile at
about 10 feet to 16 feet considering the
fact that Captain Hook fit entirely
inside this crocodiles mouth
we're much more likely to be looking at
the American crocodile
additionally or let's crocodile is only
found in freshwater environments while
the American crocodile is most often
found in salt water like you'd find off
the coast of an atoll the only downside
here is that the American crocodile is
pretty widespread as far as man-eating
reptiles go so we're looking at pretty
much the entire Caribbean in our hunt
for neverland there are also a few other
animals that I thought might narrow
things down a bit more jamberry says
that there are sea turtles and flamingos
in neverland but those are also found
all around the Caribbean the seagull
that we see Smee shave doesn't narrow it
down
the mermaids for these I even looked at
the habitats of manatees which believe
it or not are historically the animal
most commonly associated with mermaid
sightings and that still didn't aero
things down so at that point I ran out
of animals and wasn't sure if I was
looking at a dead end here but it turns
out that the last part of the theory
doesn't hinge on the animals in
Neverland
it hinges on the people according to the
source material for Peter Pan
Captain Hook was originally a bosun from
Blackbeard the pirate now Blackbeard was
very busy pirating all over the east
coast of America in the Caribbean from
17 16 to 17 18 which we stop and think
about it for carrying the title of the
most famous non fictional pirate in
history is actually not that long of a
time spent a pillaging and searching for
booty but what Blackbeard lacked in
longevity he made up for in volume
Blackbeard had a ton of instances over
that two-year period stealing wine
burning ships and blockading ports so
where does Captain Hook fit into all
this well in the spring of 17-18
Blackbeard captured a few ships in the
Gulf of Honduras right off the Yucatan
insula and added those to his fleet
specifically he was off the coast of the
turn F Atoll just east of Belize which
wouldn't you know it just happens to be
a little tropical a toll with lagoons
crocodile Schley Mingo sea turtles the
whole shebang as a bosun and
Blackbeard's fleet there's actually
historical precedent that Captain Hook
would have actually graduated up to the
role of captain on one of those
commandeered ships in the turn of the
toll in the Peter Pan story and
specifically the Jolly Roger and then
from there he drops anchor in Neverland
and then gives up his life of pillaging
in exchange for sword fighting little
boys and then outrunning a single
crocodile probably would have been
better off if he just a DuBose in there
is though one kind of glaring hole in
this that we can't really ignore if
we're going the history route wouldn't
we also have to ignore the timelines
I mean Blackbeard died in 1718 but the
darling family is clearly from the early
1900's and we even see things in the
movie like the statue of Buddha Coe
which wasn't installed until 1902 well
it turns out we don't have to ignore the
timeline even that works out under this
theory we know that once you land in
Neverland you never never grow old right
that's kind of the whole shtick of this
place well it turns out that Neverland
aka the turnip atoll is the exact
historical region believed to contain
the Fountain of Youth the one geographic
feature in the entire world that would
actually behave and function like a
real-life Neverland most of the stories
you hear about the Fountain of Youth and
history class talked a lot about pulps
de Leon who mostly looked for it around
Florida the older and much more accurate
historical hunt for it was actually
performed by one to Solis and earlier
Spanish explorer than old Hans who spent
all of his time looking for the Fountain
of Youth in the Gulf of Honduras due
mostly to really bad Spanish historical
record keeping Ponce de Leon was
actually a thousand miles off the mark
of the area that he was looking for
leaving the Fountain of Youth squarely
off the coast of Honduras and in exactly
the location we predict for Neverland so
there you have it everyone book your
Spring Break for the turn of a toll now
because it's the real location for
everlasting childhood talk about your
once-in-a-lifetime vacation but hey
that's just a theory a film theory
and cut
[Music]
you